[Musik]
so kann es klingt hier wird
ausschließlich auf instrumenten aus eis
gespielt
es ist das einzigste musik festival
europas und vermutlich das abgelegenste
euromax reporter hendrik wenning hat
sich auf den weg nach hause gemacht
hier gibt es keine straßen keine autos
nur einen bahnhof ein paar ferienhäuser
und sehr viel eis und schnee liegt im
süden norwegens in 1200 22 metern höhe
auf halber bahnstrecke zwischen bergen
und oslo
[Musik]
umgeben von gletschern eis und schnee
ist das hier wirklich der ideale ort für
ein musikfestival im vergangenen jahr
fielen die temperaturen auf minus 27
grad celsius
ausgedacht hat sich das festival tories
und der norweger hat vor 20 jahren
zufällig entdeckt wie eis klingen kann
[Musik]
ich habe mich sofort in den
fantastischen klang verliebt außerdem
sieht es sehr schön aus also dachte ich
es wäre toll ein festival zu
organisieren und viele kreative leute
einzuladen und zu schauen was man aus
eis und schnee machen kann
wir haben nur eine regel eis und schnee
müssen immer im spiel sein
mangelt es hier nicht ab dezember gehen
die festivalmacher immer wieder auf den
zugefrorenen see finze wappnet hier
werden die eisblöcke herausgesägt aus
denen später die instrumente geschnitzt
werden neun tonnen haben sie über die
monate geerntet an jeder stelle des sees
kann das eine andere qualität haben
[Musik]
die verschiedene ice typen
es liegt immer daran wie das wasser
fließt wenn es gefriert und das ist
entscheidend für den klang das hier ist
sehr klar und hat keine luftblasen
damit wird man schöne töne machen können
innerhalb weniger stunden bauen die
musiker ihre instrumente torchancen
kreiert ein element für eine marimba aus
eis und jetzt möchte ich einen höheren
ton haben
erstaunlich man kann eigentlich alle
arten von instrumenten bauen aber am
interessantesten finde ich irgendwelche
fantasie instrumental oder zumindest die
die keine reine kopie von bestehenden
instrumenten sind
dieses instrument will hendrik wenning
auf jeden fall ausprobieren
es ist eine art saxophon aus eis dass
der norwegische jazzmusiker hier zählt
möchte kreiert hat schwierig zu bauen
und noch schwieriger zu spielen
das ist so anstrengend aber einen ton
habe ich zumindest herausbekommen oder
und so soll es eigentlich klingen
[Musik]
die besucher kommen aus der ganzen welt
angereist um eines oder mehrere der acht
konzerte zu besuchen
für uns ist die erfüllung eines
lebenstraums ich komme aus italien aus
italien
und sie sind extra für das musikfestival
hierher gekommen
ja weil ich es beeindruckend und
unglaublich findet die zuschauer sitzen
bei eisiger kälte im schnee
daher dauern die konzerte oft nicht
länger als eine dreiviertelstunde praxen
oder blasinstrumente es sind oft die
leisen töne die die zuschauer berühren
[Musik]
nach drei tagen bei mais musikfestival
in norwegen geht es für hendrik wenning
wieder nach hause was bleibt sind seine
eindrücke von der landschaft und der ice
musik die hier perfekt harmonieren
[Musik]